was ging ihn durch den Kopf als sie von
dieser Tat gehört haben und welche
Informationen haben sie ich war auf dem
auf dem Weg hierher nach Hamburg im Zug
und habe Nachrichten bekommen von Leuten
die einfach nur gesehen hatten
Messerattacke im Zug und haben gefragt
wie geht's dir und
das ist einfach nur furchtbar grausam
sich vorstellen zu müssen dass es zwei
Leute gibt die heute keine Antwort
gegeben darauf haben geben können an
eine der eine geliebten ihre Familien
Hinterbliebenen und das ist einfach nur
furchtbar und ähm es ist drehen
notwendig dass man die Hintergründe auf
arbeitet um zu gucken was passiert ist
wie man wie man solches verhindern kann
aber bei dem was ich jetzt weiß und das
ist nicht viel es ist auch dringend
notwendig nicht nur an die an die Opfer
und die Hinterbliebenen Familien zu
denken und natürlich schauen wie man den
beistehen kann sondern auch mal Danke zu
sagen an all die Leute die heute
geholfen haben das war die die Leute die
vor Ort waren schnell es gibt Berichte
darüber dass Leute im Zug sich ihm
einfach in den Weg gestellt haben ich
weiß nicht ob es stimmt aber wenn es
stimmt natürlich unglaublich mutig und
heldenhafte die Bahn hat sehr viele
Leute zur Verfügung gestellt das gab
sehr schnell für sehr viele Leute die im
Zug gesehen haben diese Grausamkeiten
gesehen haben auch Seelsorge die
bereitgestellt worden ist also diese
erste Hilfe diese ersten Reaktion waren
wohl sehr gut und dafür kann man erstmal
nur Danke sagen
ach macht man so als uns aus Berlin
zugeschaltet schön guten Abend Herr
Mansour was war ihr erster Gedanke als
sie das hörten
guten Abend
ehrlich gesagt schockiert ich komme aus
einem Land die solche Daten ja
tagtäglich leider erleben musste und ich
bin deshalb auch nach Deutschland
geflohen
nach genau von Israel und ich habe das
Gefühl dass in unserem Land das ist
natürlich nur eine Gefühl ob das
statistisch Gewehr richtig oder falsch
aber in der letzten Jahren ist genau
solche Daten in Deutschland auf da ähm
passierten und das macht mich einfach
wutend fassungslos und auch traurig dann
das ist mein Heimat ich suchte hier
Sicherheit ich wollte hier Sicherheit
finden und anscheinend ist in manchen
Teilen an manchen Tagen ist genau diese
Sicherheit nicht vorhanden
Ibrahima soll 2014 hat das eben gesagt
nach Deutschland gekommen sein zunächst
NRW dann in Schleswig-Holstein gewohnt
und dann ab 2 16 subsidiären Schutz
erhalten haben können Sie kurz erklären
was das bedeutet herrmannsuhr
naja dass man halt die sozusagen der
Asylrecht nicht feststellen kann weil
man ja staatenlos ist und erstmal die
Möglichkeit bekommt in Deutschland zu
bleiben
der Mann soll wegen sexual- und
Gewaltdelikten mehrfach in Erscheinungen
getreten sein soll sich bis vor einer
Woche oder sechs Tagen noch in
Untersuchungshaft befunden haben
welchen Umgang wünschen sie sich mit
jemandem der hierher kommt der Schutz
sucht und der dann offen war immer
wieder übergriffig wird bzw nicht an
Regeln hält wie gehen wir denn damit um
wann führen wir die ehrliche Debatte
darüber
ja das ist eine gute Frage erstmal
natürlich ein so einem Abend reden wir
mutmesslich über Möglichkeiten und
Grunde die zu so ein Tat geführt haben
ich habe das Gefühl dass wir sehr oft
über die Täter sprechen zurecht über den
Täter sprechen aber wir vergessen immer
die Opfer die traumatisierten Verletzten
und ihre Familien von hier möchte ich
natürlich auch mein beileid an Menschen
die heute geliebte Menschen verloren
haben und gute Besserung an all die
Verletzten trotzdem wenn man heute
unterwegs in sozialen Medien wird man
sehr sehr schnell merken dass die
Debatte schon da ist und dass wir
vielleicht ja bis morgen warten damit
wir mehr Fakten bekommen aber in eine
postfaktische Zeitalter ist für so viele
Menschen in diesem Land Fakten erstmal
unwichtig sondern es geht um
Emotionalität die einen wollen natürlich
nur Migranten sehen und Migration alles
der Grund für solche Straftaten und die
anderen wollen über alles reden aber
nicht über Migration und genau solche
Fälle genau wie für westernacht die
Debatten die wir in Frankreich in
Schweden in Brüssel gehabt haben
natürlich ist es enorm wichtig auch über
Migration zu sprechen ich bin sehr stolz
in einem Land zu leben die Menschen die
Möglichkeit gibt Schutz zu finden wenn
sie von Krieg fliehen hier eine bessere
Zukunft aufbauen zu können aber es gibt
keine Willkommenskultur ohne
abschiebungsmöglichkeiten Menschen die
permanent wie in diesem Fall natürlich
mutmaßlich die nicht seit zwei Tagen
nicht zum ersten Mal ähm permanent
Konsequenz Straftaten begangen und
unsere rechtschaffen und darüber müssen
wir ein Weg finden diese Menschen auch
Konsequenzen zu zeigen im Extremfall
wenn es geht auch mit Abschiebung ich
weiß dass seine sehr emotionale Debatte
es ist aber eine enorm wichtige Debatte
und noch ein Punkt wir dürfen diese
Debatte nicht führen wenn es zur
Straftaten kommt viel wichtiger ist wie
funktioniert Integration wie gewinnen
wir diese Menschen für unsere
Gesellschaft wie vermitteln wir unsere
Werte und da haben wir noch einen ganz
langen Weg vor uns es gab nach allem was
man zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt weiß gegen
den Täter Ermittlungen wegen Gewalt und
Sexualdelikten aber keine Verurteilungen
ganz offenbar das ist ein juristisch
bedeutsamer Unterschied durchaus
trotzdem sagt ach mann so wie führen
insgesamt keine ehrliche Debatte der
Knobel sie als ähm
Journalist und als jemand der auch in
Berlin lebt Hauptstadt
journalistisch Spiegels wie nehmen sie
das war die Debatte rund um dieses Thema
ich glaube wir führen schon Debatten wir
führen sie halt oft
unterkomplex also so ein Fall der zeigt
ja der zeigt ja jetzt schon sehr vieles
auf über was man reden kann ohne dass
wir wissen genau was
wie die Faktenlage ist deswegen muss man
auch immer vorsichtig sein mein erster
Gedanke als ich heute im Zug saß und das
ist ja wirklich ein Moment
in dem man denkt das trifft Menschen
erstmal völlig unvermittelt
vor den Augen anderer verbunden zwei
Menschen
diesen Moment muss man sich auch immer
wieder mal machen was das was das für
die Menschen bedeutet was was für
Nachwirkungen das natürlich hat ähm und
der zweite Gedanke den ich hatte ist war
haben wir es wieder mit einem psychisch
auffälligen Menschen zu tun weil mir das
aufgefallen ist dass wir gerade bei
diesem Messerattacken sehr oft hören
dass das psychische Auffälligkeiten gab
es wird jetzt berichtet dass er
möglicherweise auch hier ein verwirrter
war
finde ich das schon mal einen Punkt über
den wir reden müssen was was tun wir mit
Menschen wann die psychisch auffällig
sind dem ist das eigentlich
möglicherweise aufgefallen auch
möglicherweise bei den Ermittlungen die
Sie angesprochen haben und das ist zum
Beispiel der zweite Punkt es ist
die die möglichen Straftaten sind über
viele Jahre passiert also es hat 2015
angefangen in dem Fall genau okay das
heißt es jetzt auch kein kein
Serientäter im klassischen Sinne dass er
dass die Abstände sehr kurz sind aber
trotzdem ist auffälliger fing glaube es
fing mit einem
Ladendiebstahl an mit einem Scheckkarten
Betrug und irgendwann kam da gefährliche
Körperverletzung und so weiter dazu wenn
wenn die Fakten so schlimm wie wir sie
jetzt kennen das heißt da findet auch
eine Entwicklung statt und ich ich
stelle mir schon die Frage wer hat
eigentlich diese sozusagen kriminelle
Entwicklung im Blick die Gerichte die
mit ihm zu tun hatten die
Ermittlungsbehörden
haben die mal geguckt
was ist das für ein Mensch wann
entwickelt sich möglicherweise so eine
psychische Auffälligkeit so also dass
das sind die ersten Fragen die mir
einfallen die Fragen die Herr Mansur
gestellt haben die sind schon auch
wichtig natürlich aber es sind ja
zunächst erstmal Menschen die hier sind
und die hier ihre kriminelle Karriere
begonnen haben und jetzt so tragisch
erstmal beendet haben
und und wir müssen erstmal mit diesen
Menschen als Gesellschaft umgehen das
Thema Abschiebungen ist auch ein
wichtiges da können wir vielleicht
gleich noch mal darüber reden aber das
ist nicht das erste Thema dass mir bei
dieser bei diesem Fall einen so hat
gerade mit dem Kopf geschütlich bin
gleich wieder bei ihnen nur wo aber
warum
naja wissen Sie wir haben
2020 laut die Tageszeitung Welt um die
20.000 Messerattacken gehabt mit fast
100 Tote davon sind 40 Prozent Menschen
mit Migrationshintergrund oder ohne die
deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft das ist ein
Zahl der Zeit wir haben hier ein Problem
und zwar nicht nur in diesem Fall die
wissen wirklich viel zu wenig über heute
Abend aber wenn wir die letzten Jahren
anschauen dann haben wir ein Problem von
Menschen die bei uns Schutz suchen und
dieses Land teilweise verachten und
bereits sind auch andere Menschen zu
verletzen oder
Polizeibeamte anzugreifen Feuerwehr
Leute anzugreifen all das gehört zu
Debatte genauso wie das was sie vorher
erwähnt haben natürlich spielt
psychischer Erkrankungen auch eine Rolle
aber ich frage mich warum wir nach Halle
und Hanau zurecht nicht nur
ausschließlich von psychischer Labilität
gesprochen haben da waren auch Menschen
die psychisch krank oder mindestens
labil sind wir haben zu Recht über die
Ideologie gesprochen warum tun wir das
in diesem Fall nicht und den Fälle wenn
es um Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund
trefft die natürlich auch zum Teil
ihre Grunde haben warum man sozusagen
Straftaten begangen hat aber auch
Sozialisation auch ähm
Herkunft auch Erziehungsmethoden aber
auch die Tatsache dass Menschen die bei
uns Schutz gesucht haben und teilweise
krimineller werden sind Themen die
erwähnt werden müssen wenn wir eine
ehrliche Debatte führen wollen sie
wollten gerade ja es ist richtig dass
man sich die Hintergründe ganz massive
angucken muss nur heute abend weiß ich
nicht was der Hintergründe sind
nebeneinander aber es war war der Mensch
im Drogen raus weil er ist natürlich
stabil ist da vielleicht in Verbindung
mit einer dschihadistischen
terroristischen Organisation hatte das
alles akribisch geplant aus irgendeinem
kriminellen Hintergrund den ich nicht
kenne ich weiß das alles nicht erstens
zweitens natürlich müssen wir über
Abschiebungen auch reden überhaupt keine
Frage und es gibt auch keine keine keine
debattenverbote aber sie haben gerade
den Unterschied gemacht der Land
zwischen nicht Verurteilung und und
Ermittlung ja der Rechtsstaat kann ich
Leute bestrafen wenn sie nicht
verurteilt sind das ist der Kern vom
Rechtsstaat und subsidäre Schutz
bedeutet dass es massive rechtliche und
auch andere Hindernisse gibt für eine
Abschiebung so ja das ist quasi einmal
das was darf man ganz kurz einhaken weil
sie sagen
das ist der Rechtsstaat und der
funktioniert immer so da bin ich völlig
Beine meine Frage wäre dennoch bei
jemandem wie in diesem Fall und noch mal
immer sehr vorsichtig formuliert nach
allem was wir heute abend wissen wenn da
jemand ist der nicht verurteilt ist
offenkundig der aber ganz offenkundig
dennoch auf der anderen Seite auffällig
geworden ist wegen sexueller
übergriffigkeiten was auch immer dann
die einzelnen Taten sind wenn das stimmt
was glaube gerade berichtet also es
beginnt mit Ladendiebstahl und wird dann
irgendwann deutlich massiver
wie gehen wir denn damit um also müssen
wir aus aus rechtsstaatlichen Gedanken
heraus und aus einer
demokratischen Toleranz heraus von
formuliere ich einfach mal uns das dann
alles gefallen lassen dürfen dann keine
Zeitpunkt sagen pass auf wenn du ein
Mitglied dieser Gesellschaft werden
möchtest das von diesem Land was
erwartet und auch erwarten darf
aber gleichzeitig auch was einbringen
möchte dann bist Du jederzeit willkommen
aber wenn du das machst dann hast du
dein Recht verwirkt hier zu sein dass
hier alles alles richtig und der Begriff
Toleranz führt der komplett in die Irre
das sind ja zwei verschiedene der Fall
heute abend es gab diesen diesen
fürchterlichen Fall in bei Neu-Ulm in
Iller Kirchberg
da begann die Frage ob man ob man den
Täter nicht abschieben muss der der ist
das Afghanistan
oder es gab einen anderen Fall genau das
ist voll von Friedrich Merse Geschichte
ganz kurz ich will nur einmal kurz die
Fakten weil sie das gerade ansprechen
also die Kirchberg zwei Geschichten in
der Kirchberg gab es diesen
fürchterlichen Fall eines retriebischen
Asylbewerbers habe ich das im Kopf der
ja zwei Mädchen auf dem Weg zur Schule
mit einem Messer angreift eine dieser
Taten die in dieser eben erwähnten
Statistik auftauchen ein Mädchen davon
stirbt grauenvoll auch ein mit
Migrationshintergrund übrigens und die
zweite Geschichte ich glaube 2019
Asylunterkunft auch in Illerkirchberg es
kommt in dieser Unterkunft zu einer
gruppenvergewaltigung
drei Männer einer davon aus Afghanistan
die eine 14-Jährige mit Drogen betäuben
und Überstunden missbrauchen dann
verurteilt werden und wenig später ist
einer von denen der Afghane von dem sie
gerade sprechen ist wieder frei weil
seine Strafe verbüßt ist dass
baden-württembergische Innenministerium
sagt der würde ich jetzt gerne
abschieben das Justizministerium will
ihn abschieben so ist es und dann kommt
Nancy fazer bundesinnenministerin und
sagt geht nicht weil ähm ist Afghanistan
ist es ist zu gefährlich sagen Sie mir
aber ist die ist die Antwort dann darauf
dass eine
gemeindewählerkirchberg ich meine ich
frage mich mal was das mit so einem Ort
macht wenn das passiert was jüngst
passiert ist und wenn dann im Hinterkopf
noch sitzt das was 2019 passiert ist wie
erklärt man das Menschen total richtig
genau die richtige Frage ich Teil des
her ich will nur auf folgendes hinaus
erstens wir müssen natürlich alles
ausschöpfen was er Recht hat mit sich
bringt um um nicht solche Taten zu
verhüten sondern vor allem wenn sie
geschehen sind was was hoffentlich dann
nicht mal passiert und wo wir es können
verhüten müssen es wird also in dem Fall
ist es so dass es um die Debatte ging wo
bringt man in Zukunft und keine einzige
Gemeinde war bereit diesen jungen Mann
diesen Verurteilten Vergewaltiger
aufzunehmen wir sagen den wollen wir
nicht haben und ich kann das gut
nachvollziehen kann das auch
nachvollziehen das Thema nochmal es sind
zwei verschiedene eine ist was macht der
recht stark und wie wie schöpfen wir die
Mittel das Recht hat alle aus und tun
wir das gibt es genug Personal in der
Justiz gibt es genug Polizisten ganz
tolle testen das ist das eine das zweite
ist wie kommen wir denn dazu und das ist
die Debatte von Ahmet man zur verhüten
damit solche Dinge passieren und ich
würde das in den in der Tönung komplett
anders sehen als er und da muss man
darüber diskutieren das ist die eine
richtige wichtige Debatte die man führen
muss aber natürlich muss man alles dafür
tun damit damit man Menschen die Gesetze
erklärt und und ihn im übrigen auch
darstellt
das funktioniert bei ganz vielen Leuten
und es gibt es gibt bei vielen Leuten
die Boys nicht funktioniert und das ist
natürlich auch eine Frage das ist nicht
zwingend eine Frage das Hintergrund ist
aber es gibt natürlich Fälle wo der
Hintergrund mit reinspielt bei der Frage
von von Umgang mit äh mit mit sexueller
Gewalt vor allem haben wir es natürlich
auch zu tun mit Leuten die die teilweise
aus Ausländern kommen ein Problem
hier in diesem Raum schon mal gesessen
in diese Sendung und haben darüber
gesprochen dass es Leute gibt die auf
dem Schulhof erstmal lernen dass Israel
zerstört werden muss das ist äh dass die
die den Antisemitismus derjenige waren
sie ne mir ist es in der Schule auch
erzählt worden so natürlich ist das
notwendig diese ganz kurze Hintergrund
geboren aufgewachsen und haben dann
erzählt wie sie in ihrer Schule in
Frankfurt das erste Mal sozusagen vom
vom Holocaust überhaupt erfahren haben
und haben auch erzählt wie sie
indoktriniert worden sind wie man jeden
Morgen in Teheran sozusagen erstmal
da rein durfte in die Klasse musste man
sowas rufen und natürlich muss man
schauen dass es nicht nur darum geht
dass man irgendwie mit mit äh dass man
quasi wedelt und sage es ist hier ganz
süß und es wäre schön wenn du dich an
Richtung Gesetz hält sondern das muss
natürlich auch die Stränge haben die die
es braucht aber hattest die die muss es
haben und das ist der gesamte
gesellschaftliche Aufgabe das ist
zuweilen jeweils ein Einzelfall und vor
allem ist es geht auch darum dass wir
bei den ganzen Integrationsfragen
vielleicht ein Stückchen mal drauf
schauen müssen ob es in den Kommunen
funktioniert weil dort gelingt es oder
misslingt ist und wir sind viel zu viel
in den ganzen reflexdebatten ist das
jetzt eigentlich die Migration oder
dürfen wir nicht über Migration reden
ich teile was was an dieser Stelle
gesagt hat aber die Antwort darauf muss
ja sein dass man konkret jeweils schaut
wo funktioniert das und was funktioniert
das vor Ort in in meiner Stadt Frankfurt
muss die Debatte anders laufen als als
auf dem Land das verstehe ich aber ich
ich sorry ich kann das Argument kann ich
nicht nachvollziehen in der Kirchberg
z.B also sie erwecken gerade den
Eindruck als wäre sozusagen ein ein die
ein Problem von Elia Kirchberg die Frage
wie die Community dort mit jemandem
umgeht und dann wird
verstanden
Lösungen passgenau sein müssen und und
wir mit den ganz großen antworten wir
machen jetzt mal multikultina wir machen
gleich Vorankommen sondern die Kommunen
brauchen
wir brauchen die Mittel dafür die
brauchen einen rechtlichen Rahmen die
müssen die Möglichkeit haben auch auch
best fruccess anzugehen und das ist das
Thema es geht nicht um darum zu sagen
dass die Schuld sind es geht darum dass
die Lösungen nur dort am Ende des Tages
erarbeitet und funktioniert ich schaue
gerade noch mal zu Ahmad Mansour der
den ich gerne fragen würde die
Konsequenz des Rechtsstaats die
Umsetzung von geltendem Recht haben Sie
das Gefühl dass wir darin wirklich gut
sind
nein nein leider nicht ich sage Ihnen
auch warum also wenn Sie zum Beispiel
die Art und Weise wie manche
Jugendkulturen und hier rede ich nicht
nur von Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund aber auch mit zum
Beispiel Polizisten und Polizisten
umgehen dann muss ich sagen da haben wir
eine enorme Nachholbedarf und das
Silvester nach zeigt ja dass diese
Respektlosigkeit nicht von ungefähr
kommt sondern sie ist Teil von Prozesse
die in den letzten Jahren gestartet
haben wenn Polizisten mir immer wieder
erzählen bei Verhaftungen werden sie von
jugendlicher zu hören bekommen ach warum
tust du das ich bin in zwei Stunden
wieder da und verkauft meinen Drogen
dann muss ich sagen das funktioniert
nicht wenn ich schaue dass Menschen die
permanent Konsequenz unserer Rechtsstaat
verachten und ich sage es noch mal
Menschen die bei uns Schutz gesucht
haben die wir die Tore aufgemacht haben
die wir aufgenommen haben und trotzdem
wie am Silvesternacht in Köln Mass super
sexuelle Belästigung gegenüber Frauen
veranstalten dann muss ich sagen nein
natürlich gibt viele Bereiche wo
Menschen vielleicht auch
trotz unsere Maßnahmen sich integrieren
und dass wir großartiger Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund haben und
Flüchtlinge die Zeit fünf sechs Jahren
bei uns leben und schon längst
angekommen sind Freiheit orientiert mit
solchen Fällen nicht zu tun das alles
gibt es aber trotzdem glaube ich so
lange wir das Gefühl vermitteln dass
unser Rechtsstaat schwach ist werden wir
Leute haben die diese Schwäche ausnutzen
die das Gefühl haben sie können hier
alles leisten und wir haben keine
Konsequenzen zu tragen ich arbeite z.B
im JVA in Bayern und treffe sehr oft auf
junge Menschen die mir sagen ach mein
Fehler war dass ich in Bayern inhaftiert
wurde werde ich in Nordrhein-Westfalen
oder in Berlin wäre ich schon längst
draußen also auch innerhalb Deutschland
gibt's Unterschiede und das ist genau
bei dieser Gruppe die sowieso autoritär
erzogen werden die patriarchalische
Strukturen erlebt hat erlebt unsere
demokratische Rechtsstaat die Menschen
zweite dritte Chance gibt nicht alles
Schanze sondern alles Schwäche und da
müssen wir viel besser werden und besser
werden wenn wir wirklich diese wirklich
schlimme Straftaten diese Menschen die
permanent unser Rechtsstaat verachten
auch klarer Konsequenzen zeigen und wenn
es geht natürlich mit demokratischer
rechtmittel auch abschieben
apropos Abschiebung ich will doch mal
ganz deutlich sagen ne wir reden heute
Abend nicht über Migranten generell
weil ohne
Migranten würde dieses Land hier an
vielen Stellen schon lange nicht mehr
gut funktionieren wir brauchen diese wir
brauchen noch ein paar wir brauchen
diese Leute aber wir reden jetzt sind
drei Migranten
ja genau genommen ja und der Punkt ist
aber wir reden über kriminelle und die
Frage warum ist der Rechtsstaat da so
schwach sie haben sich nur eine
rückführungsoffensive in den
Koalitionsvertrag geschrieben
im ersten Halbjahr sind nicht mal 2% der
300.000 ausreisepflichtigen rückgeführt
worden wo bleibt die Offensive
das ist immer eine Frage des aushandeln
mit den Ländern in denen die Leute hin
müssen erstens ist die die
grundsätzliche Frage natürlich auch der
Integrationsleistung die der zwischen
geleistet worden ist und wenn man das
bedenkt und wenn man auch jetzt sich
anschaut dass ich jetzt ja auch
beispielsweise Familien gibt die die
seit Jahren in Ketten Duldungen sind und
dass wir das jetzt beenden sie mir nicht
mal bei 300.000 aber das ist richtig gut
dass sie den Punkt machen aber noch mal
der der harte Kern derer von denen wir
als Gesellschaft sagen euch wollen wir
hier nicht haben ja weil ihr seid
kriminell geworden er hat vielleicht
Frauen vergewaltigt die haben Menschen
umgebracht er handelt massiv mit Drogen
wir wollen euch nicht mehr hier haben
das dann übrigens auch viele Migranten
sagen das sagen warum lasst ihr euch das
gefallen warum warum zieht ihr an dem
Punkt nicht einfach darum geht
dazu sagen das eine ist aber man so hat
er zum Beispiel Silvester die silvestern
aber richtig ist da jetzt eine
Grundhaltung dass man einfach machen
kann was man will und und das ist ein
riesen Problem deswegen ein Thema weil
die meisten von denen offenkundig
erklären
es gibt glaube ich ein ein Irrtum in der
gesamten Diskussion und und das ist
diese Anmutung naja das sind ganz
schlimme Leute die kommen aus ich nehme
jetzt mal Tunesien das ist jetzt aber
ein aktives Beispiel und deshalb freut
sich Tunesien diese Leute aufzunehmen
und das ist ja nicht der Fall und da
gibt es ein paar Leute die glauben man
geht einfach ein bisschen rum und dann
gib mal ein bisschen Geld und dann sagen
die Leute dann nehmen wir halt alle auch
das ist nicht zwingender der Fall das
heißt das ist immer eine
Aushandlungsprozess und das ist eine
ganz schwierige Angelegenheit ehrlich es
gibt manche die so gefährlich sind wo
ich sagen würde die sind eine größere
Gefahr für auch die deutschen Interessen
und für unsere Sicherheit wenn Sie bei
uns im Gefängnis sind und und nicht da
draußen irgendwo herumlaufen gerade aus
dem dialistischen Bereich
ihre rückführungsoffensive auch auch
eine Mogelpackung weil weil die
Schwierigkeiten sind ja nach wie vor da
Herr Lanz hat er gerade die Zahlen
benannt es ist ein geringer Prozent
derjenigen die eigentlich ausreisen
müssten die dann ausreißen und das hat
viele Ursachen dass man die Dokumente
nicht hat dass man mit den Herrn dass
die Herkunftsländer niemanden
zurücknehmen es hat ein Jahr gebraucht
bis äh
rückführungsbeauftragte der
Bundesregierung endlich installiert
wurde das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt
ein Zeichen dafür dass man das unbedingt
ganz schnell machen wollte und die Frage
ist auch wirklich was kann man denn
erreichen was kann man mehr erreichen
die EU versucht das jetzt auf auf
europäischer Ebene das ist vielleicht
sinnvoll wenn mehrere Länder zusammen
mit Herkunftsländern verhandeln und da
geht ja auch am Ende immer Umwelt
nimmt so viele dafür kriegt er was er
sich wie viel Geld oder oder sonstige
Geschenke wie gesagt das hat Grenzen ich
glaube das ist eine Illusion zu glauben
das war mit Geld die Bereitschaft genau
und deswegen ist die Frage was wo wo
liegt die Offensive dann also die
erstens haben wir ein ganzes Paket und
die offensiv ist ja ein Teil davon und
für die einfach einen anderen
abgearbeitet zweitens habe ich ja gerade
beschrieben wir haben jetzt das heißt
Chancen Aufenthaltsgesetz da geht es um
diejenigen die den kettenduldigungen
sind die ihre Integrationsleistung
erbracht haben und jetzt trotzdem
inzwischen Baum und Borke hängen und und
wenn man das alles zusammenzieht dann
sind wir ja bei bei unter 100000 glaube
ich wir haben tatsächlich das dritte ist
ähm diese Leute meine ich geht es nicht
ja
dieser deutschen Gesellschaft und zwar
sowohl der migrantischen als auch der
Bier und deutschen unter
Anführungszeichen jederzeit vermitteln
dass jemand der was möchte in diesem
Land oder nicht straffällig wird
selbstverständlich willkommen
in Relation setzen das Thema und ja
sondern es ist ja gerade von allen
gesagt worden wir haben gerade wenn ich
gehe viel durch den inbetriebe oder rede
mit mit Unternehmern es ist ein massives
Problem dass wir in diesem Land haben
mit mit fehlenden Arbeitskräften wir
reden ja gar nicht mehr über Fachkräfte
und er ist Migration nicht die Lösung
aber aber ganz oft quasi eine schnelle
Überbrückung von von von Lücken die die
wir haben und dann wir haben es ja
gesehen bei unserem Flughafen in
Frankfurt haben Leute gefehlt die die
Koffer von den Bändern holen dann hat
man gesagt dann holen Sie aus der Türkei
und am Ende hat mein Bruchteil von dem
bekommen was man überhaupt gebraucht
normal
da sind wir bei Integration der offenbar
unfassbar schlecht wir sagen ja dann
häufig Menschen mit Qualifikation aber
selbst in unqualifizierte Jobs kriegen
ja keine Leute rein die wir eigentlich
hier haben also wenn wenn 40 % der Syrer
die 2015/2016 ähm gekommen sind heute in
Arbeit sind dann bedeutet es dass 60%
nicht im Arbeitsmarkt integriert sind
und die Frage warum sind wir da so
schlecht
Kinder und so
arbeitsfähige Menschen aber das ist ein
ganz anderes Thema wir reden über die
Frage warum
ich will gar nicht ausweichen wir werden
wie gesagt wir haben einen ganz großes
Paket an den Maßnahmen die wir die wir
machen wollen die wir miteinander
verabredet haben und wir werden das
alles alles machen als als Koalition und
das die Zahl 300.000 sind gerade genannt
haben die ist ja jetzt keine die jetzt
irgendwie gestern irgendwie aufgelaufen
ist sondern die ist ja über Jahre
gewachsen und dann schauen wir mal wo
wir wo wir jetzt die nächsten Jahre so
hinkommen ich will vor vorne Illusion
der noch warnen ich wie gesagt ich weiß
nicht was heute heute Nachmittag
passiert ist ich kenne den Hintergrund
nicht es wird immer wieder Fälle geben
die die dramatisch sind und und wir
werden alles dafür tun müssen damit
keine familienangabe ihre lieben Leute
stehen weil sie gerade
furchtbar am Ende des Tages werden wir
nur
alles dafür tun müssen um den
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt auch zu
stärken damit eben diejenigen die solche
Leute auch als Rattenfänger zu sich
ziehen sei es in die klaren Kriminalität
sei es eben in irgendwelche
radikalen Strukturen damit die nicht
Wasser auf ihre Mühlen bekommen darf ich
abschließend noch mal Ahmad Mansur
Fragen
dieser Tage eine Statistik aus
Baden-Württemberg gelesen das sind viele
Menschen aus Gambia
98% der Menschen denen wir auch Asyl
bitten 98% haben keine Ausweisdokumente
bei sich
deswegen ist es unglaublich schwer auch
da Leute die kriminell geworden sind und
die tauchen in der
baden-württembergischen drogenstatistik
Drogenhandel Statistik Kriminalität
signifikant häufig auf deswegen würde
man sie gerne zurückbringen nach Gambia
geht aber nicht aus diversen Gründen
unter anderem auch weil der Präsident
aus Gambia das mitunter verhindert hat
das System dieses dieses sozusagen
dieses dieses Ausnutzen eines eines
Systems eines Asylsystems kann man so
was würden Sie sagen
ich würde natürlich nicht
verallgemeinern es gibt viele Menschen
die den Weg nach Europa machen weil sie
hier eine bessere Zukunft haben wollen
und die dürfen wir natürlich auch nicht
vernachlässigen in der Diskussion es
gibt aber eine Gruppe die ganz genau
weiß wie sie hier sozusagen ihre
Aufenthalt sichert und wie kommt schon
mit krimineller Energie und mit einer
gewisse ja Verachtung gegenüber
Rechtsstaat sie wissen ganz genau woher
sie kommen wie sie aufgewachsen sind
aber geben sie das nicht zu und mit
diese Gruppe müssen wir irgendwie
klarkommen und natürlich reden wie immer
wieder überspitzt aber Abschiebungen das
ist natürlich eine Möglichkeit um solche
Leute loszuwerden aber wir dürfen nicht
vergessen dass wir auch ganz ganz viele
Menschen haben die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft haben und kriminell
geworden und auch da funktioniert die
recht stark nicht so wunderbar dass sie
auch abschreckend werden das heißt auch
da müssen wir unser Justiz verbessern
wir müssen Straftaten besser verfolgen
wir müssen mit den Richter und
Richterinnen sprechen dass eine Null
toleranz-politik auch herrschte damit
die für Menschen auch zwei drei Mal
darüber nachdenken ob ein Straftat
sozusagen sich lohnt all das gehört auch
dazu und ich sehe das alles eine
Gesamtpaket natürlich erstmal
Integration versucht diese Menschen zu
gewinnen und die kriminelle mit
unterschiedlichen Möglichkeiten
versuchen ihn klar zu machen dass
Kriminalität sich nicht lohnt erlauben
Sie mir aber noch einen Satz dazu dann
wenn wir über Zusammenhalt sprechen
sprechen wir nicht über eine Floskel und
Zusammenhalt schafft man nicht indem man
Debatten verweigert und indem man nicht
ehrlich miteinander spricht wir sind
kurz davor diese Gesellschaft so
zugespalten dass viele die vielleicht
auch eine Skepsis haben vielleicht nach
heute Abend auch Fragen haben die nicht
beantwortet werden in die Richtung
rechtsradikale zu verlieren das haben
wir in Schweden und in Fernseher
deutlich gesehen und ich hoffe dass die
demokratische Parteien die Verantwortung
verstehen die wie jetzt haben und
versuchen wirklich diese Debatte zu
führen vor allem Lösungen anzubieten es
geht nicht darum zu sprechen es geht
darum auch diese Menschen auch er
antwortet zu geben dass Sie sich sicher
fühlen und das Gefühl haben dass unsere
Regierung handelt und nicht bei
Populisten dann die antworte suchen die
letztendlich keine Antwort sind